la collection high tech challenger ses
concorde
un avion de rêve qui tous les jours
franchi l'atlantique à plus de deux fois
la vitesse du son
outre magazine de la collection le monde
insolite des robots qui peu à peu nous
envahissent un peu plus dans notre vie
quotidienne
high tech challenger c'est aussi le tgv
est un voyage époustouflant à 515 km
heure
la haute technologie en vidéo c'est bien
sûr l'espace et tous ces satellites qui
gravitent nuit et jour où dessus de nos
têtes
le rafale l'avion invisible français et
bien d'autres aux technologies sont
aussi dans la collection high tech
challenge s
reconstitués et reproduire à l'infini
les mouvements les plus sophistiqués
c'est bien là tout l'enjeu est toute la
difficulté de la robotique
passé en trente ans de la science
fiction à la réalité industrielle la
robotique c'est aujourd'hui plus de
200000 robots en service dans le monde
les robots et leurs cousins germains les
automates font désormais partie de notre
vie quotidienne
il assemble construisent conduisent
parle se déplace et reconnaissent même
les formes qu'on leur présente ou le
milieu dans lequel ils évoluent
doté du seul savoir transmis par l'homme
les robots sont devenus aujourd'hui
expert comme nous et l'intelligence
artificielle s'élance monde insolite est
extraordinaire que nous allons
maintenant pénétrer
centrale nucléaire edf de gravelines
dans le nord six tranches de 900
mégawatts chacune une des cinquante
centrales françaises de la filière
réacteurs à eau pressurisée
un lieu de prédilection pour les robots
et pour les automates
car leurs interventions permettent de
limiter ici au maximum la présence des
hommes dans les zones où la
radioactivité est élevée
une robotisation qui permet à
electricité de france d'améliorer du
même coup la sécurité de ses personnels
et sa productivité
le dernier né des robots utilisés ici
c'est easy ce2 / lieu d'intervention les
boîtes à eau des générateurs de vapeur
un générateur de vapeur c'est une énorme
cocotte-minute de 20 mètres de haut pour
un diamètre moyen de 4 m c'est là où
l'eau chauffée par le coeur du réacteur
libère ses calories c'est pour
intervenir dans ce monde très
inhospitalier lors des arrêts programmés
de la centrale qui disent d'eux a été
conçue développée par hispano suiza pour
le compte d'edf
isis 2 c'est un robot porter d'outils de
près de cinq mètres de long
possédant 8 degrés de liberté un robot
de troisième génération qui dès son
entrée dans la boîte à eau procède par
télémétrie laser à une phase
d'initialisation au cours de celle ci il
va reconnaître les lieux dans lesquels
il va devoir évoluer identifier son
environnement et comparer la topographie
réel à celle qu'on lui a apprise
fixer directement sur le générateur de
vapeur isis est désormais capable
d'effectuer avec la plus grande
précision les tâches les plus
minutieuses
ici la pose d'une pièce appelée contre
anneau permettant de fixer une nouvelle
génération d'obturateur sur la
tuyauterie garantissant ainsi la
parfaite étanchéité du circuit primaire
de la centrale lors des interventions
dans le générateur de vapeur
cette opération très délicate comme
toute intervention aux centrales
nucléaires d'un homme d'un robot d'un
outil ou les trois à la fois doit être
répété de nombreuses fois et a prouvé
dans un centre edf spécialisée appelée
seddik car en configuration réelle
il n'y a pas le droit à l'erreur la
précision du geste de est étonnante
il peut identifier un à un les 3390 tube
d'une boîte à eau des générateurs de
vapeur est posé sur les tubes défaillant
des bouchons de la taille d'un dé à
coudre mais déjà chez hispano suiza on
envisage de marine ise et 6 2 afin de
pouvoir intervenir automatiquement et en
toute sécurité dans les piscines des
centrales nucléaires
prudence prudence le bonheur ou encore
des siennes région parisienne
mon présent bouteille âge dans le sens
province paris attachez vos ceintures et
visibilité réduite et 1er août à
l'introduction progressive de
l'informatique embarquée dans la voiture
de monsieur tout le monde
si elle prévient de la panne sèche ou de
la porte mal fermée n'est pas
suffisamment sophistiqué pour asservir
un automate de conduite
en l'air il en va déjà depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années tout autrement en
croisière c'est généralement le pilote
automatique qui guident l'avion
l'équipage ne faisant pendant un vol
stabiliser normal que surveiller dehors
comme dedans
on
ce sont de véritables ordinateurs de
bord a servi à des sortes de gyroscopes
appelé plateforme à inertie guide et
maintiennent l'avion dans les trois
dimensions des automates
agissant sur les gouvernent et sur les
commandes des réacteurs
les automates embarqués dans les avions
et notamment sur les airbus d'air inter
prennent toute leur importance dans les
phases d'approché et d'atterrissage en
période de visibilité réduite au sol ou
en présence de brouillards une procédure
appelée i rs ou atterrissages aux
instruments
les atterrissages en catégorie 3 permet
de se poser avec une visibilité
horizontale de 200 m et une visibilité
verticale de 20 mètres mais pour
réaliser un att un atterrissage tout
temps l'avion l'équipage et la piste
doivent tous trois être qualifiés et
homologué c'est une première série de
balises appelé local either qui
maintiennent l'avion sur le plan de sa
trajectoire horizontale d'autres balises
donnant une plante idéale à l'avion en
le maintenant en permanence sur le cloud
sorte de raï fictif touchant le sol
au seuil de piste
nous
les deux combinés permettant à l'avion
de réaliser un atterrissage entièrement
automatique
et si l'un des trois acteurs de la
trilogie homme machine terrain n'est pas
qualifié l'alchimie de l'atterrissage
tout dans est impossible
après la théorie beaucoup plus
spectaculaire est la pratique réalisé
dans le poste de pilotage d'un airbus
d'air inter tout commence à 1700 pieds
un peu plus de 500 mètres du sol
regardez herbert 125 et 125 rappeler au
sol ou en remise légal
à temps
200 150
80 is all out et romano
en vingt ans les équipages des rats
terre ont réalisé plus de 6000
atterrissage comme celui ci un record
mondial
l'aéronautique ont la vue est un des
domaines d'application privilégié pour
les automates mais aussi pour les robots
qui s'il n'a semble pas encore les
avions ou leur moteur contrôler leur
fabrication
ici ce sont des éléments des réacteurs
cfm56 construits par la snecma qui vont
être passées à la loupe
ou plus exactement radiographier avant
d'être remontés on s'intéressera plus
particulièrement aux différentes soudure
afin d'en contrôler la bonne homogénéité
cobra c'est le nom de ce robot de
contrôle radiographique de pièces à
géométries complexes développées par
hispano suiza cobra vient chercher un
par un les films dans leur conteneur
plombé et les plats sur la zone exacte à
examiner
cobra positionne et oriente
automatiquement la source de rayons x 1
puis toujours tenue par la passe du
robot cobra le film exposé est ensuite
replacé dans un conteneur de protection
l'opération totale ne durera que 45
secondes
cobra permet un contrôle non destructif
de toutes les grandes pièces très
sophistiqué fabriqué par les industries
aéronautiques ou nucléaires il peut
effectuer tous types d' examens
radiographiques par rayons x ou
endoscopique
l'introduction de la robotique dans ce
domaine cela veut dire un accroissement
de la productivité pour les industriels
avec des gains de temps sur chaque cycle
de l'ordre de 50% mais aussi
l'augmentation de la sécurité pour le
produit final
un argument à ne pas négliger quand il
s'agit comme ici d'un réacteur d'avion
il est inutile de rappeler qu'en
production
les robots sont depuis déjà bien
longtemps passé maître dans le contrôle
de la qualité
si on sait on l'a vu diriger et faire
atterrir automatiquement un avion par
temps de brouillard
on ne sait toujours pas aujourd'hui
faire rouler une voiture sans conducteur
de paris à marseille et cela même sur
autoroute
et pourtant les projets les plus fous ne
manquent pas ordinateur de bord système
à crémaillère fils enterrés ou peinture
sur le sol comme cela existe en usine
pour le déplacement automatique des
chariots de manutention mais et grands
constructeurs comme psa continue à
défricher le terrain comme ici au centre
de belchamp des images réellement
étonnante
l'industrie automobile mondiale
confrontée à la concurrence japonaise
est aujourd'hui très grosse
consommatrice de robots pilotés par les
systèmes informatiques de plus en plus
perfectionnés les robots peuvent être
programmés pour exécuter les tâches les
plus diverses manutention transfert ou
conditionnement de pièces mécaniques
assemblage et soudage et les tripes par
point ou à l'arc montage peinture ou
découpe au laser le monde privilégier
les robots c'est celui des tâches
dangereuses pénibles ou répétitives
associé à d'autres machines outils à des
convoyeurs installations également
programmables éventuellement connecter à
des ordinateurs munis d'écrans graphique
pour la conception informatisé des
pièces les robots s'intègre aujourd'hui
dans les cellules et les ateliers
flexible de production
le travail robotisée contrairement aux
idées largement répandue n'est pas un
travail à la chaîne
réalisé par des robots imbéciles mais
bien une nouvelle conception très souple
des moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour
produire au moins de recours
le développement galopant de
l'informatique et de la cfao la
conception et la fabrication assistée
par ordinateur
cela veut dire pour les années 90 la
naissance du sinn d'un nouveau type d
usine
cette fois entièrement automatique gérés
par des réseaux d'ordinateurs
interconnecté assurant seul des
productions programmées
alors seulement lé voiture achetée neuve
pour ont littéralement recevoir le label
deux voitures de première main à moins
que d'ici là les robots est acquis
l'intelligence artificielle
m
on est
les mécanismes utilisés pour actionner
ses machines foraines sont réellement
d'une autre époque
par rapport à ce qui se passe ici dans
le sous-sol de l'île ici c'est le monde
duval véhicule automatique léger conçu
et développé par matra transport un
métro sans conducteur
l'automatisation en matière de transport
c'est avant tout la recherche de la
sécurité maximum confié à toute une
batterie d'ordinateurs de
microprocesseurs et même de véritables
capteurs intelligents corrigeant eux
mêmes leurs erreurs toute une
infrastructure informatique conçu pour
assurer à l'ensemble du système
une fiabilité optimales de
fonctionnement
comme il est utopique sur un
microprocesseur et sur les milliers de
transistors qui le compose de prévoir
les conséquences de l'ensemble des
pannes possible l'idée ici a été
d'associer à toute anomalie de
fonctionnement d'un quelconque des
circuits informatiques du système
l'arrêt immédiat du train
après une période de tests d'essais et
de qualifications le val de l'isle à
transporter depuis sa mise en service en
plus de 250 millions de passagers sans
aucun accident dans le poste de contrôle
et de commande
les opérateurs suivent en temps réel la
bonne marge globale de l'ensemble du
réseau
la règle étant qu'en fonctionnement
normal le personnel d'exploitation
n'intervient pas les écrans de
télévision et l'affichage synoptique de
tous les sous systèmes ne sont en fait
que des aides à la décision
précieux en cas de problème agression ou
vandalisme par exemple pour surveiller
l'ensemble un système appelé terry
supervision 400 caméras placées aux
points stratégiques mais aussi un
véritable réseau de télé mesures
permettant l'intervention à distance et
la détection automatique des anomalies
anomalie sur l'un quelconque des
véhicules mais aussi sur les
sous-systèmes que ce soit la billetterie
les escaliers mécaniques ou les portes
palières le val de l'isle c'est pour les
passagers une rame automatique toutes
les une à trois minutes et cela 20
heures par jour le métro automatique
c'est aujourd'hui aussi en france
orlyval une desserte à 50 km heure de
l'aéroport parisien
et puis à partir de 1993 toulouse
bordeaux rennes et la ligne numéro 2 de
lille pour roubaix tourcoing des métros
automatiques aux couleurs françaises
ici à jacksonville en floride à
l'aéroport de chicago à taiwan ou à
turin en italie
des robots appelés val véritable vitrine
de la haute technologie made in europe
à l'heure de la guerre électronique et
des moyens d'attac ou de défense de plus
en plus sophistiqués robes ou comme
automates ont trouvé ici de multiples
emplois les avions de chasse répondent
aujourd'hui à la voix de leurs pilotes
les radars embarqués fixent eux mêmes la
trajectoire idéale à suivre les missiles
guidés ou non par laser font mouche à
tout coup
parmi ces ambres auditables le missile
mistral conçu et produit par matra
défense est une sorte de tomates
construit par des robots ce sont en
effet des robots qui assemble seuls ces
missiles capables après lancement de
rejoindre seules leurs cibles et cela
sans aucune intervention humaine
une chaîne d'assemblage unique en europe
et probablement aussi au monde qui
assure automatiquement sur la partie
pyrotechnique du missile toute une série
d'opérations assemblage du tronçon avant
de son propulseur et de sa charge
introduction du missile dans son tube
fixation de l'embout cryogénique mêmes
tests les munitions sont réalisés sans
aucune intervention humaine
dans cette usine matra manurhin de seine
saint denis dans le loir et cher on
assemble de la sorte 200 missiles par
mois sa capacité globale étant de
l'ordre du millier
toute une série de manipulations
automatique contrôlé par un ensemble de
caméras vidéo surveillant les points
sensibles des installations
ici robotique signifie comme
généralement gains de productivité mais
aussi sécurité pour les personnes et les
biens
avec une réduction maximale de tout
risque d'explosion
des robots privé de la parole ce qui
contribue à renforcer très largement la
confidentialité du programme mistral un
programme stratégique
des automates imaginé par l'homme créant
leur propre alchimie pour le guérir
on est bien loin aujourd'hui de ces
unique remède fournis par la nature
seule bouée de sauvetage sur l'océan de
la souffrance de la maladie de la
vieillesse et de la mort des molécules
qui s'assemblent se marient ou se
désunit secrètement dans les mémoires
glace et des automates et puis une
nouvelle naissance
un nouvel espoir
le liquide même de la vie le sang passe
lui aussi avant d'être transfusés par
les censeurs des automates et leurs yeux
perçants comme des lasers qui le
déshabillent le met à nu à la trappe de
la moindre impuretés
ainsi même la vie est devenue chiffres
code-barres pourcentage numéros anonymes
que seul automates et robots peuvent
reconnaître et identifier sans erreur et
cela en une fraction de seconde
un monde une durée une abstraction qui
aujourd'hui permet de courir le marathon
alors que l'homme n'était le but
programmée que pour courir le 100 m
sur les chaînes de conditionnement de
médicaments comme ici à l'établissement
de colomiers près de toulouse de sanofi
pharma industrie là aussi pour des
raisons d'hygiène de sécurité bien sûr
de productivité les automates sont
omniprésents siro suppositoire ampoules
et aérosols sont le temps d'une
révérence
les acteurs anonymes d'un ballet
soigneusement réglée par des automates
pour le plus grand plaisir des yeux
mariage harmonieux et précis du contenu
et du contenant symphonie achevée
imaginé par l'homme mais exécutée par
des centaines de tomates en dés millions
de mesures parfaitement identiques
à
palis sécurité civile et experts
militaires de tous les pays sont très
demandeurs de toutes nouvelles
technologies en la matière robot
démineur au robot capable d'aller seul
dans les zones polluées ou dangereuses
comme les deux androïdes de la guerre
des étoiles les robots aujourd'hui son
mobile et autonome et peuvent se
déplacer quel que soit le terrain
rencontrer ils peuvent voir grâce aux
caméras de télévision dont il sent nous
mêmes touchés en utilisant des capteurs
tactiles sorte de peau artificielle
l'étape qui restent ici encore
maintenant à franchir dans le secret des
laboratoires et celle de l'intelligence
artificielle dont on est en train de
doter ces robots mais pour des raisons
facilement compréhensible les
scientifiques en la matière sont peu
bavards
ces créations de science fiction sont
désormais remises et au musée des robots
témoins des balbutiements de cette
technologie qui a aujourd'hui tout juste
30 ans
à
dans les stations orbitales du futur
homme mi robot cohabiteront les robots
pour tous les travaux de construction
des infrastructures spatiales
le chargement et le déchargement des
véhicules la réparation des satellites
puis plus tard sur la lune ou sur mars
pour toutes les tâches industrielles
l'homme consacrant lui exclusivement son
temps au travail intelligent
l'homme ainsi libérées par les robots de
toutes contraintes matérielles dans sa
vie quotidienne devra alors prendre
garde de ne pas devenir à son tour leurs
esclaves
on